Wenn Galaxien zusammenstoßen und verschmelzen,
ist das ein wirklich ein mehr als spektakuläres
Ereignis.
Die interstellaren Gaswolken prallen dabei
mit voller Wucht aufeinander.
Dabei werden Sterne innerhalb der beiden ursprünglichen
Galaxien aus ihren Bahnen geschleudert und
zudem entstehen massenhaft neue Sterne.
Jetzt wurde eine wirklich beeindruckende Aufnahme
einer solchen Galaxien-Kollision veröffentlicht,
die einer Kamera des Hubble-Weltraumteleskopes
gelungen ist.
Schaut also zu, wie zwei Galaxien miteinander
verschmelzen und erfahrt, warum und wann genau
solch ein Schicksal auch unserer Milchstraße
droht - jetzt bei Clixoom Science & Fiction;
herzlich willkommen!
Schon 1784 wurde das verschmelzende Galaxien-Paar
namens NGC 6052 entdeckt.
Und zwar von dem britischen Astronom William
Herschel.
Konkret befindet sich das Galaxien-Paar im
Sternbild Herkules und ist rund 216 Millionen
Lichtjahre entfernt.
Doch die Form des Galaxien-Paares ist verwirrend
und führte Astronomen-Teams weltweit lange
auf eine falsche Fährte.
Deswegen gingen Fachleute lange davon aus,
dass es sich bei NGC 6052 um eine einzelne
Galaxie handelt.
Erst später erkannte man dann, dass dies
nicht der Fall ist und stattdessen zwei Galaxien
miteinander verschmelzen.
Der “Wide Field Camera 3” des Hubble-Weltraumteleskopes
ist eine wirklich irre Aufnahme von diesem
Ereignis gelungen.
Solche Aufnahmen von kosmischen Crashs sind
wirklich Hammer.
Dennoch kann man die dabei stattfindenden
Wechselwirkungen kaum erahnen.
Wenn Galaxien kollidieren, beeinflusst dies
in enormen Ausmaß die Entwicklung der beteiligten
Galaxien.
Das Gefüge der dünn verteilten interstellaren
Materie wird durcheinandergebracht: Sie verwirbelt,
es bilden sich Wolken und Millionen an neuen
Sternen entstehen.
Die beteiligten Sterne selbst fliegen ungehindert
aneinander vorbei und auch die Planetensysteme
um sie herum werden nicht gestört - dem weiten
interstellaren Raum sei Dank.
Die beiden Crash-Galaxien verändern durch
eine Kollision dennoch ihre Erscheinung.
Wenn zwei oder mehr Spiralgalaxien verschmelzen,
entstehen beispielsweise so genannte elliptische
Galaxien.
Durch Kollisionen von Galaxien sind übrigens
unsere Sonne und die Planeten entstanden.
Und auch sehr spannend: Unserem Milchstraßen-System
steht wohl auch noch ein solches Ereignis
bevor.
Anfang des Jahres hatte ein britisches Forschungsteam
diesen Galaxien-Crash genauer berechnet.
Demnach wird unsere Heimatgalaxie in etwa
2,4 Milliarden Jahren mit der “Großen Magellanschen
Wolke” kollidieren.
Das ist eine Zwerggalaxie in nächster Nachbarschaft,
die aus rund 15 Milliarden Sternen besteht.
Sie umkreist unsere Heimatgalaxie in rund
163.999 Lichtjahren Entfernung und bewegt
sich derzeit noch langsam von der Milchstraße
weg.
Die Simulation eines Supercomputers legt aber
nahe, dass sich die Zwerggalaxie in Zukunft
verlangsamen wird und sich wieder auf die
Milchstraße zubewegt.
Die Fachleute gehen davon aus, dass unser
Sonnensystem bei diesem Crash aus seiner Bahn
geschleudert wird.
Dazu einer der beteiligten Forscher Marius
Cautun: “Während zwei Milliarden Jahre
verglichen mit einem Menschenleben sehr lang
sind, ist es nach kosmischen Maßstäben eine
kurze Zeit.”
Und der Crash wird fatale Folgen haben: Das
zentrale Schwarze Loch im Zentrum der Milchstraße
wird aktiv und sich gigantische Mengen an
Materie einverleiben.
So könnte es auf die achtfache Masse anwachsen.
Laut Marius Cautun wird der Crash folgendermaßen
enden: “Dieses Phänomen wird mächtige
Jets energiereicher Strahlung erzeugen, die
knapp außerhalb des Schwarzen Lochs entspringen”.
Sterne könnten aus der Scheibe der Milchstraße
ins Halo geschleudert wer also die kugelförmige
Hülle um unsere Galaxie den, das wiederum
auf das Fünffache anwachsen würde.
Ebenso ins Halo geschleudert würde dann wohl
unser Sonnensystem.
Doch ein kleiner Trost für das Leben auf
der Erde: In dieser Zeit wird die Sonne sich
bereits zu einem Roten Riesenstern aufgebläht
haben, sodass ein Leben auf der Erde so oder
so unmöglich ist.
Die zwanzig schönsten Galaxien - Aufgenommen
vom Hubble Weltraumteleskop und erläutert
von Raumzeit Vlog der Zukunft.
Draufklicken, anschauen und abonnieren würde
ich mal sagen.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!